what is your favorite sex position we're
gonna play the newlywed game the way it
works is one person answers a series of
relationship questions and then the
other person tries to guess their
answers excuse me are you guys dating
No your best friends you're not dating
okay cool are you guys dating by chance
no okay you guys want to answer some
questions about relationships what is
your favorite sex position I don't think
I could answer this question sighs
romantic stuff her on her knees yeah
definitely doggy style doggy stuff
that's it let's bring a man to back come
on back Michelle what is his favorite
sex position sex position Oh on top he
likes me on top
I guess what I don't know okay
missionary I'm telling you that's it
doggystyle doggystyle
is that right I like everything but
that's not what I asked
is that correct it's many favorite ways
but not the one I vote no oh god she's
that doggy style
he said right okay yeah that's correct
what he's been that is correct
oh man we're having a vote